10 Awful Scenes In Amazing Movies
It’s very rare that you can claim a movie
is absolutely perfect.
Sometimes even our most beloved movies can
contain scenes that for one reason or another
just don’t seem to gel with the rest of
the film.
These are the scenes you take a bathroom break
during, fast forward, or just sit there wondering
what the filmmakers were thinking.
You’ve seen our 10 Amazing Scenes In Terrible
movies, now here’s 10 Awful Scenes in Amazing
Movies.
The Breakfast Club
Considered by many to be one of the best high
school films of all time, 1985’s The Breakfast
Club was marketed as a realistic look at the
lives of teens in the 80s.
In one scene, several of the characters get
high in the library, but the pot has a strange
effect on Emilio Estevez’s jock character
who for some reason decides to hot box a room
on his own before going into a high energy
dance, complete with gymnastics and shadow
boxing.
He caps this odd sequence by shattering a
window with his powerful scream.
I’ll have what he’s having.
Django Unchained
By the third act of Quentin Tarantino’s
Django Unchained, several of the film’s
main characters have been killed off and we
expect the former slave’s final revenge
to be imminent, instead a narrative detour
is taken to make room for the director’s
worst cameo to date.
Taking Django away from Candyland not only
stops the film’s action dead in its tracks,
but it also contains a highly questionable
Australian accent from Tarantino who should
have left this sequence on the cutting room
floor.
Interstellar
Christopher Nolan’s sci-fi epic prided itself
in being more science than fiction, but one
of the film’s key emotional moments contained
a bit too much whimsy for most viewers.
Doctor Brand’s speech about love transcending
time and space seemed a little out of place
in this largely cerebral thriller and rubbed
a lot of audiences the wrong way.
Ultimately the speech didn’t really contradict
the film’s themes, the writing was just
a little too on-the-nose for most of us to
stomach.
Star Wars
In 1977, audiences didn’t yet know the full
history of Obi Wan Kenobi and Darth Vader,
nor had they ever seen a lightsaber duel,
so when the two faced off there was little
in the way of expectations to be met.
Looking back at the blockbuster classic, this
fight does not hold up, but seems stiff, lifeless,
and completely lacking in the action and emotion
that even the following film, The Empire Strikes
Back, was able to achieve with its lightsaber
duel between Vader and Luke.
Lord of the Rings -The Fellowship of the Ring
In the first Lord of the Rings film, the hobbits
had their own little adventure before the
fellowship had even formed.
While on Weathertop, Frodo receives a wound
from a Ringwraith that almost kills him.
When he comes to in Rivendell, he believes
his journey has come to an end, and Peter
Jackson treats it like an epilogue, one that
will later be echoed in the many epilogues
of Return of the King.
The hobbits have a gleeful reunion and talk
of going back to the Shire, but with two and
half movies remaining we know their journey
is just beginning and watching them celebrate
feels as redundant as second breakfast.
The Master
P.T.
Anderson’s last few films have been anything
but straightforward.
The director likes to challenge his audiences
with complicated characters behaving strangely.
The Master depicts the unlikely friendship
between a troubled world war II veteran and
the leader of new religious movement.
The dialogue in their final meeting has all
the meaning of a nonsensical dream and concludes
with the master inexplicably singing lyrics
to the jazz standard ‘(I’d like to get
you on a ) Slow boat to china”.
Ambiguity is one thing, but this is just confusing.
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows part
The trend of breaking up popular franchise
conclusions into two parts can often result
in some pretty blatant filler scenes.
Perhaps the best example of this is Harry
and Hermione’s awkward dance in Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows part 1.
It’s a grim point in the film for the characters
and this is Harry’s attempt to lighten the
mood, but Harry’s goofy dance moves paired
with Nick Cave’s brooding music make for
a strange and uncomfortable moment.
Clearly Hermione doesn’t know how to react
to this either.
Thanks for the Grade 8 dance flashback Harry.
Drive
Despite its art film proclivities, most of
Drive follows a somewhat rational logic that
seems to go out the window when the driver
sets his sights on Nino, the despicable gangster
played by Ron Pearlman.
For no apparent reason, the driver dons a
creepy mask and stares at Nino through the
window of a crowded restaurant for an extended
period of time as if he were a character in
a horror film.
He doesn’t enter, but instead walks back
to his car so he can use it to ram Nino’s
off a cliff.
Still masked, the driver confronts his bloodied
victim on the beach and stares him down for
a few moments before Nino decides to help
him finish the job by running into the ocean
where he can be easily drowned by the driver.
Thanks for not making this weird Nino!
Gangs of New York
Martin Scorsese’s 2002 flick attempted to
depict gang warfare as it was in mid-19th
Century New York.
The opening sequence sees Bill the Butcher’s
gang face off against Priest Vallon’s gang
of Irish immigrants, and begins with promise
as we feel we’re in the competent hands
of a master filmmaker.
Then all of a sudden the character known as
“Hellcat Maggie” literally flies through
the air, pounces on a victim and bites off
his ear.
At this point the scene becomes something
else entirely.
The music changes to a synthy modern rock
soundtrack and what follows looks like the
man who gave us Raging Bull decided to let
his teenaged nephew direct for a day.
It was an odd choice to begin a film that
would contain no further scenes shot, edited
or scored using this style that looks more
like an ultra violent music video than a feature
film.
Captain America: Winter Soldier
Captain America: Winter Soldier is one of
the highest rated Marvel movies to date.
One of the reasons for this was the plot’s
many twists and turns.
One red herring involved Nick Fury faking
his death.
Just so there’s no doubt left in the audience’s
mind, we’re made to witness several minutes
of characters wordlessly watching doctors
try to revive him.
They even ran out of reaction shots and felt
it necessary to include this one where Black
Widow is clearly speaking but her dialogue
has been cut.
Once he’s been pronounced dead, Black Widow
decides she needs an even closer look, you
know, to poke him and make sure he’s not
faking it.
What did you think of our 10 Awful Scenes
from Amazing Movies?
Did we leave any out?
Be sure to let us know in the comment section
below!